[Music]  The Huffington Post this was a big story  reported that female news anchors that  major TV networks are being pressured to  show more skin and wear revealing  clothes on the air apparently they're  being pressured to do this to boost  ratings well I watch a lot of news I  don't think it's just the female anchors  who were feeling the pressure violent  threat 18 the potential path as severe  storms are on the move with a dramatic  drop on the way now that some labs at  the CDC are being accused of operating  with the same rules as your employee  break room at work Congress wants  answers looks amazing I'd say it's very  nice skin yes  you